let's do this
boom
for the first time ever we're bringing
together an international all-star cast
of ex-islanders ready for a second
chance at love
and down for some healthy competitions
let the games begin I'm back whether you
like it or not
this time there's a whole nother ball
game I am so excited there is flavors
from all corners of the Earth in one
Villa it would be so fun to fall in love
with somebody who's not from America
let's hope the girls like an Aussie
accent and they can get down under
get me looking hot and get me some six
packs that I can touch
see I look good right if I want
something I'm gonna get it
I'm definitely gonna give it my all
I'll do whatever it takes to win if I
have to play dirty I'm gonna play dirty
I need number one not second not third
not full I want number one I think I've
got what it takes to win the challenges
if they're like physical but if they're
like this about like being smart
this time around I'm gonna give my heart
but I'm going for the money
I'm going in looking for the full
package right I love everything that
comes with love my heart's open it's
gonna be explosive
I'm so ready for the games all eyes are
definitely gonna be on me when I walk
into that Villa let's do this it's game
time
[Music]
love Island games only on peacock I'm
gonna be in this game okay